i've been photographing the queen for
just under 20 years now as getty images
real photographer
the queen was an absolutely incredible
person to photograph i mean people talk
about her aura and that is no
understatement
she walks into a room for her it was
just another day at work but for the
people she's meeting she met it could
have been one of the most exciting days
of her life and i think she understood
that you know she always wore bright
colors she knew that everyone wanted to
see her and she was the focus of
everyone's attention i think she
respected that and i think that was a
really important part of her character
but to photograph her was a huge
privilege um she was definitely in her
latter
years uh it was less of a regular
occurrence but that meant it was all the
more special so she was an incredible
person for photograph i photographed her
a few times in the last few months i
think one of the most special times was
the platinum jubilee of course we all
remember her on the balcony appearing
for that final platinum jubilee
appearance where no one was quite sure
if she'd actually be able to make it and
so it was a pretty emotional moment when
she came out wearing green she looked
out across a sea of people and i think
she must have been quite emotional at
that moment and it was you know a really
incredible few days of platinum jubilee
very special i think that all eyes of
the world were on london that week my
job as a raw photographer is to record
these moments so i've been up and down
the country from scotland to wales not
only recording
um
events with the queen and the coffin
traveling around the country but also
events with the new king prince charles
i also work with him photographing him
so we've been seeing him traveling all
around the country and i think it has
been a really surreal moment when i
first
heard the news that the queen had sadly
passed away i was in windsor and i was
on a bridge because i gone down to
photograph windsor castle and an amazing
rainbow appeared over the rain tower
and it was probably one of the most
unforgettable moments of my life
incredibly surreal as i watched the flag
go down to half mast this rainbow
appeared and it was just an incredibly
poignant moment and my phone buzzed with
the news that the queen had sadly passed
away
[Music]
it was a lovely touch to see prince
george and princess charlotte at the
funeral of course you know
it's probably the first female they've
been to it must have been a weird
experience for them i think in but also
historic and very important bearing in
mind their position within the family
and how how the historical context of
that is so important so i think you know
it was very touching to see them there
poignant see the family and sad at the
same time i've been lucky to photograph
the family all together and capture some
of those those lovely family moments and
one of my favorite pictures actually is
the prince george chatting to the queen
at princess charlotte's christening and
he's pointing up looking at a hat who
knows what they're saying but it's just
a lovely moment and every opportunity
you get to photograph the family
together was was really special things
like christenings births
weddings it was always a really rare but
special opportunity photographing um
well now prince wales prince william
with the queen there's so many lovely
moments i can think back of over the
years lots of you know one in particular
where the queen's looking for her
spectacles at the
um the festival of remembrance in the
royal albert hall and they're laughing
together of course trooping color we
always saw some lovely kind of
interactive moments between the queen
and prince william and prince harry and
they i think they all had an incredibly
warm relationship certainly symbiotic
you know the queen
taught all the members of the royal
family so much about duty about you know
from her just lifetime of experience and
and she
loved having them there supporting her
at the same time so it's very much a
symbiotic relationship but also just
incredibly warm and loving family
relationships
[Music]
it was lovely to see not only the duke
and duchess of sussex but also the now
prince and princess of wales come out
and view flowers and tributes to the
queen outside windsor castle that was
very special to see everyone together
it was amazing to see such a huge crowd
of people it's a beautiful sunny
afternoon they walked out together to
view the tributes to the queen i think
it's you know it's lovely to see
everyone together it's you know it's a
very sad time for the family but it's
clear that you know it has sort of
united everyone in some sense i mean the
queen definitely had a great sense of
humor i was lucky enough to photograph
her you know not only official portraits
but you know images with the family for
me it was always those candid moments
she never played up to the camera she or
you know that's why you had to be on the
ball to capture those those like
flickers of emotion or interactions with
people that she met and i've got so many
pictures
that really remind me of that sense of
humor one of my favorite actually was at
the royal albert hall where she got this
cake the knife stuck in the cake she was
meant to be cutting and princess anne
had to help her and safety wettings were
there and everyone burst into laughter
and it's just those kind of natural
moments are the ones that i love to
capture as a photographer and they're a
little bit more kind of insightful than
the more formal uh formal pictures i
mean and i've photographed the king a
lot huge amount all around the world and
you know he's fantastic to photograph i
think he's going to be a great king
alongside camilla who's a huge support
to him in the queen console and i've
just been so lucky to photograph and i
think taking before he's obviously
learned a lot from his mother he's going
to take that sense of duty forward when
we're on royal royal trip to the board
he completes up to eight engagements a
day he doesn't have lunch he's got a
real energy for someone who a nature and
many people have retired it's an
incredible uh attitude so yeah i think
he would do a huge amount he clearly had
an incredible relationship with his
mother you just have to look at images
of them at highland games and the
interaction between them both and i
think that was very special but i think
um seeing him over the last week it's
been incredibly difficult for him i've
got a few favorites of the queen one of
the ones i took earlier this year was an
official picture to commemorate her
accession day which is the day she
became queen taken up in sandringham
somewhat she obviously feels very
comfortable she's working on her red box
her iconic red box which she gets her
notes in
every day of the year apart from
christmas and easter and she's laughing
and i love that moment because for me
that sums up her character that
commitment to duty taken this year so
you know not that long ago and she was
committed to duty right to the end and
she enjoyed it i also took one um at a
place called the lister hospital up in
stevenage and it was on one of her
day-to-day royal engagements and the
great thing is about doing those
covering all that side of her life is
you never quite know what's going to
happen in front of you that's a great
thing about being a raw photographer the
the unexpected the anticipation and the
light dropped in a really nice way and
she was chatting some nurses and it was
a nice clean background it was kind of a
cheeky expression and
for that subtlety of expression is kind
of a really endearing photograph and
that's one of my favorites i was so
lucky to photograph prince philip and
the queen
for their 73rd wedding anniversary and
official picture in
windsor castle and you've got the round
hair in the background and prince
phillips opening up a card from his
great grandchildren princess sharna
prince louis and prince george and for
me it's like a candid photo game it's
just a lovely moment you can see the
prince kind of lights that when he opens
the card and i think for anyone to reach
their 73rd wedding anniversary it's an
amazing achievement um royal royal kind
of side aside but you know it that was
particularly poignant and you could see
their relationship and i think
it was again symbiotic they were they
they gave strength to each other
throughout their life prince philip was
an amazing support for the queen on all
raw tours all around the world and and
so you know to see them both together
into together in windsor i think that
that's going to be very emotional after
prince philip passed
there was a couple of engagements and it
must mean a very difficult time for the
queen but
i remember photographing the queen at a
pared-down
troop in the colour ceremony in windsor
castle and she was tapping her foot to
the music she was smiling
and she you know incredibly positive and
actually there was lots of engagements
um a few months after the duke pass
where the queen was on absolutely top
form um of course you know he knows what
she's thinking inside but she she really
um took on engagements with a positivity
after a period of mourning and i think
of course she was incredibly sad about
the duke's passing but she she embraced
work i think and
i was just next to the state entrance
for the funeral right in the midst of it
so the coffin came out of windsor castle
right next to me it was
the most somber
sad moment as the royal family processed
along of course it was covered time so
there was only 30 members of family
allowed there and i will never forget
actually seeing that photograph the shot
of the queen sitting in the pew on her
own was just such a powerful image
and you know it really was an
illustration of the the cavity times and
the difficulties difficulties that she
had so
you know very powerful imagery though
the queen was definitely a fashion icon
i mean i i'll never forget her
appearances at royal ascot or ask the
traditional british horse racing week
that we have in the summer and i mean
ascot's going to be a very sad place
without the queen she was royal ascot
her passion for horse racing was
well known but
the day she won the gold cup ascot i'll
never forget
but you know people bet on the colour of
her hats every day you know that people
were fascinated by the queen's fashion
she always wore bright colours so she
could be spotted in the crowd she knew
how important it was that people could
see her she once said i have to be seen
to be believed that was so true and that
influenced the way she dressed and she
always looked incredibly elegant she had
milliners who put her hats together
beautiful embroidery and you know there
was culturally sensitive dressing
diplomatic dressing when she was on a
raw turtle island you know in green
canada in red australia
so she
had that respect you know history was
kind of essentially woven into the
clothes that she wore
often she would combine
gifts and materials she'd received and
and they'd be incorporated into the
clothes she wore uh so that you know
there was a real history to how she
dressed and you know cultural
sensitivity and you know so many
different factors so it's absolutely
fascinating you could write a whole book
on the queen's fashion the data on the
gold cup say this was an incredible day
so her horse estimate powered over the
finishing line and i will never forget
the atmosphere it was incredible she was
the first monarch in over 207 years to
win
the biggest horse racing trophy i mean
the queen was given her first horse at
the age of four peggy
and from then on there was a life of
passion for breeding horses racing
horses and to see the look on her face
when she was handed the gold cup it just
really went to show how much that meant
to her and you know it was an incredible
moment
[Music]
you